Uh, there's a new report that if true is the
most shocking revelation in the entire Jamal
Khashoggi fiasco since its inception.
And if this is actually true, it's actually
arguably much worse than the Ukraine scandal,
which is already a major, major scandal.
The spectator is reporting that whistleblowers
can allege with evidence.
That's whistleblowers plural, that Donald
son in law, Jared Cushner personally gave
the green light personally okayed on the phone
with Saudi crown Prince Mohammad bin Solomon
to go ahead and arrest journalist Jamal Khashoggi,
who of course we know after being arrested
was killed and dismembered at the Saudi Arabian
consulate in Istanbul, Turkey.
Um, the gravity of this is, is almost inconceivable
to have the whistle blowers out of the seven
that are involved generally in this report
from the spectator to have the whistleblowers
involved here reportedly are in agreement
about this.
And it is apparently not just an assertion,
but one of the two whistle blowers says that
an intercepted phone call that is in the possession
of Turkish and child intelligence, uh, actually
is the conversation during which this took
place.
The phone call is reportedly between Jared
Cushner, himself and Mohammad bin Solman himself.
And I have even more to discuss with this
because of something that I said.
Uh, a little while back, the existence of
this phone call is said to have been the way
that Turkish president Erdogan was able to
convince or strong armed Donald Trump into
pulling troops from Syria.
Now, this is still early, but that allegation
is one that I hypothesized about at the start
of the Syria fiasco.
And a lot of people wrote to me saying, David,
that is baseless speculation and you were
wrong to do it.
Well, it's certainly speculative.
This is an analysis and commentary show and
that's one of the things that we do.
We speculate, but there were reasons to do
that.
Speculation primarily that there was no sensible
explanation for the timing of Donald Trump's
decision to pull troops from Syria.
This is my clip from three weeks ago, and
a lot of people were angry with me for it.
Take a listen and then we start to speculate.
Does Erdle one have some things so bad on
the killing of Jamal Shoji that if it were
to get out, it would be even more devastating
that Donald Trump didn't do a damn thing about
it instead selling more weapons to Saudi Arabia?
It's a possibility.
Yeah.
That is now exactly what is being alleged.
That urge to one has something so bad on Trump
that Trump's son in law personally okayed
to Mohammad bin Salman the arrest of Jamal
Shoji in this case, which led to KASHO, jeez
killing that.
He was able to force Donald Trump to pull
troops out of Syria.
So there are actually two scandals here and
the reporting that I'm seeing is mostly about
just one of those scandals.
So scandal number one, if indeed Jared Kushner,
Trump's son-in-law, unelected, not confirmed
by the Senate, an advisor to Donald Trump.
If Jared Cushner personally told Muhammad
bin Solman to go ahead and arrest a Washington
post journalist, that is a scandal of highest
degree.
We are talking colloquially, I'm not making
a legal argument.
I'm not a lawyer.
We are talking colloquially about conspiracy
to commit murder.
Although of course they'll never be held accountable.
We know that, but it goes further than that.
If this phone call being recorded, put Turkey
in a position to be able to strong arm Donald
Trump to haphazardly pull troops from Northern
Syria in direct contradiction to what any
of Donald Trump's generals or the Pentagon
or the state department were suggesting, which
led to the deaths of Kurds.
It's leading to the possible resurgence of
ISIS.
It is an absolute travesty and a tragedy of
foreign policy and it is the complete subjugation
of the office of the presidency at our expense
for the benefit of foreign governments.
Now we have to be careful here because this
is one story from the spectator.
We want corroboration of the story.
We eventually, ideally we'll get the actual
whistleblower testimony on this because it's
not just if the story is false, if even some
element of the story is not exactly as described,
we already know that the Trumpists will jump
all over it as fake news, as evidence of the
media is corruption, and even if the story
is off by a fraction, they will discredit
the entire thing.
But the truth is the opposite.
If even a fraction of this story is true,
if one whistle blower says Cushner okayed
the arrest of [inaudible] Shoji instead of
two, if Turkey did strong arm Trump on troops
in Syria using anything related to KASHO G,
if any element of this story is true, it is
a scandal of the highest order that, I mean,
listen, I'm still trying to process the entire
thing and with scandal fatigue, they all start
to sort of blend together, but my immediate
impression is that this is arguably bigger
than any other scandal of the Trump presidency
because of the gravity and disgusting vile
nature of it.
That is what is being alleged as of right
now.
By the time you listen to this, by the time
you watch this, maybe we will know more in
a week.
Who knows what we will know, but this is number
one, not very different from what we have
suspected for a very long time.
With regard to the Turkish strong arming of
Trump and Jared Kushner is unelected, he was
not confirmed by the Senate.
It is the crony stick nepotism that Donald
Trump, I guess said he was going to eliminate
by draining the swamp and blood.
All of that stuff.
It hasn't happened.
It's worse than we could have ever imagined.